sion spéciale ce soir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce lundi
emmanuel macron s'exprimera dans une
poignée de minutes en direct de l'elysée
allocution très attendue par les
français qui n'ont en grande majorité
pas confiance dans le gouvernement pour
gérer cette crise selon un dernier
sondage ifop pour le journal du dimanche
le président de la république devrait
notamment préciser les contours de la
prolongation du confinement france
débuté le 17 mars nous décrypterons
évidemment ce discours avec nos invités
[Musique]
la france qui se rapproche du cap des 15
mille morts depuis le début de
l'épidémie du coronavirus le pays se
situant dans une phase de hauts plateaux
c'est ce qu'indique ce soir la direction
générale de la santé dans un communiqué
dans les hôpitaux on dénombre 3 135
décès de plus en 24 heures le solde d
admission en réanimation et pour le
cinquième jour consécutif négatif de 24
patients
et puis les autorités sanitaires
mondiales appellent l a1 déconfinement
lent plus de 114 mille personnes mortes
dans le monde
lié à ce virus en europe l'autriche elle
se prépare à rouvrir partiellement ses
commerces alors que l'espagne dessert
d'un cran son confinement autorisons une
reprise partielle du travail dans les
industries notamment aux états unis pays
le plus touché désormais dans notre
homme souhaiterait lui un déconfinement
dès le 1er mai
[Musique]
emmanuel macron doit donc s'exprimer
précisément à 20h02 après les
applaudissements quotidien des français
aux soignants nous rejoignons notre
reporter thomas bonnet en direct devant
l'elysée bonsoir thomas à quelle annonce
doit-on s'attendre ce soir
le président de la république de
répondre à de très nombreuses questions
que se posent les français et la
première d'entre elles c'est jusqu'à
quand vont durer ces mesures de
confinement on a peu de doute sur le
fait que le président de la république
va annoncer une prolongation mais la
question maintenant c'est de savoir
jusqu'à quand
et puis l'autre grande question c'est
celle du déconfinement sous quelle forme
aura lieu ce déconfinement de bratton
porter des masques at on suffisamment de
masques pour l'ensemble de la population
il y aura-t-il des tests également pour
permettre le déconfinement voilà l'autre
grande question le président de la
république qui devrait également aborder
la réouverture des établissements
scolaires pourront-ils rouvrira à fond
avant les vacances d'été voilà encore
une question que se pose un certain
nombre de français et puis le président
de la république devrait évidemment
aborder l'après crise sanitaire et
économique avec notamment par exemple la
tenue ou non au second tour des
élections et merci thomas bonne et on va
tout de suite écouter emmanuel macron
mes chers compatriotes nous sommes en
train de vivre des jours difficiles nous
ressentons tous en ce moment la peur
l'angoissé pour nos parents pour nous
mêmes face à ce virus redoutable
invisible imprévisible la fatigue et la
lassitude pour certains le deuil et le
chagrin pour d'autres cette période est
encore plus difficile à vivre lorsqu'on
habite à plusieurs dans un appartement
exigu
lorsqu'on ne dispose pas à chez soi des
moyens de communication nécessaires pour
apprendre se distraire et changer encore
plus difficile à vivre
lorsque les tensions sont là que les
risques de violence dans la famille
scande le quotidien et nous mesurons
tous dans cette période la solitude et
la tristesse de nos aînés
et pourtant grâce à nos efforts chaque
jour nous avons progressé nos
fonctionnaires et personnels de santé
médecins infirmiers aides soignants
ambulanciers secouriste nos militaires
nos pompiers nos pharmaciens ont donné
dans cette première ligne toute leur
énergie pour sauver des vies est soigné
ils ont tenu les hôpitaux français ont
réussi à soigner tous ceux qui s'y
présenter ces journées ces semaines ont
été et resteront l'honneur de nos
soignants en ville comme à l'hôpital
dans la deuxième ligne
nos agriculteurs nos enseignants nos
chauffeurs routiers livreur électricien
manutentionnaire caissiers et caissières
nos éboueurs personnel de sécurité et de
nettoyage
nos fonctionnaires nos journalistes nos
travailleurs sociaux nos mères et nos
élus locaux et j'en oublie tellement
aidé par tant de français qui se sont
engagés tous ont permis à la vie de
continuer au fond et chacun d'entre vous
dans ce que j'ai appelé cette troisième
ligne
chacun d'entre vous par votre civisme en
respectant les règles de confinement
grâce aussi à la vigilance de nos
policiers de nos gendarmes
vous avez fait que l'épidémie commence à
marquer le pas les résultats sont là
plus j'ai eu plusieurs régions ont pu
être épargnés
depuis quelques jours les entrées en
réanimation diminue l'espoir renaît et
je veux ce soir vous remercier très
chaleureusement pour ce dévouement et
vous dire toute ma reconnaissance
alors étions nous préparer à cette crise
à l'évidence pas assez mais nous avons
fait face en france comme partout
ailleurs
nous avons donc dû parer à l'urgence
prendre des décisions difficiles à
partir d'informations partielles
souvent changeante nous adapter et sans
cesse car ce virus était inconnue et il
porte encore aujourd'hui beaucoup de
mystère le moment trion annette a révélé
des failles des insuffisances comme tous
les pays du monde
nous avons manqué de blues de gants de
gel hydroalcoolique
nous n'avons pas pu distribuer autant de
masques que nous l'aurions voulu pour
nos soignants pour les personnels
s'occupant de nos aînés pour les
infirmières les aides à domicile dès
l'instant où ces problèmes ont été
identifiés
nous nous sommes mobilisés gouvernement
collectivités locales industriels
associations pour produire et pour
acquérir le matériel nécessaire mais je
mesure pleinement que lorsque l'on est
au front il est difficile d'entendre
qu'une pénurie mondiale empêche les
livraisons les commandes sont désormais
passées surtout nos entreprises
françaises et nos travailleurs ont
répondu présent et une production comme
en temps de guerre s'est mise en place
nous avons réouvert des lignes pour
produire nous avons réquisitionné d'ici
trois semaines nous aurons imaginer le
multiplier par cinq la production de
masques pour nos soignants en france et
nous aurons produit des 1000 respirateur
supplémentaires de plus sur notre sol
c'est respirateur si précieux en
réanimation
grâce à ces efforts nous saurons faire
face et nous allons continuer à
distribuer davantage d'équipements mais
comme vous j'ai vu des ratés encore trop
de lenteur de procédures inutiles des
faiblesses aussi de notre logistique
nous en tirerons toutes les conséquences
en temps voulu quand il s'agira de nous
réorganiser ces dernières semaines
soyons aussi juste avec notre pays ont
été marquées par de vraies réussites le
doublement du nombre de lits en
réanimation ce qui n'avait jamais
été atteint les coopération inédite
entre l'hôpital les cliniques privées et
la médecine de ville
le transfert de patients vers les
régions les moins touchées mais aussi
vers le luxembourg la suisse l'allemagne
et l'autriche que je remercie la mise en
place de l'enseignement à distance
l'organisation de chaîne de solidarité
dans nos communes
la réussite de tous ceux qui nous ont
nourris durant ces semaines sans rupture
avec engagement le rapatriement de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
ressortissants français et européens
depuis des pays du monde entier et le
soutien aux français de l'étranger
très souvent ce qui semblait impossible
depuis des années nous avons su le faire
en quelques jours nous avons innové osé
agir au plus près du terrain
beaucoup de solutions ont été trouvées
nous devrons nous en souvenir car ce
sont autant de forces pour le futur mes
chers compatriotes si je tenais à
m'adresser à vous ce soir après avoir
largement consulté ces derniers jours
c'est pour vous dire en toute
transparence ce qui nous attend pour les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois
l'espoir renaît je vous le disais oui
mais rien n'est acquis dans le grand est
comme en ile-de-france les services
hospitaliers sont saturés partout en
hexagone comme dans les outre-mer le
système est sous tension et l'épidémie
n'est pas encore maîtrisée nous devons
donc poursuivre nos efforts et continuer
d'appliquer les règles plus elles seront
respectées
plus nous sauverons de vie
c'est pour cela que le confinement le
plus strict doit encore se poursuivre
jusqu'au lundi 11 mai c'est durant cette
période le seul moyen d'agir
efficacement
c'est la condition pour ralentir encore
davantage la propagation du virus
réussir à retrouver des places
disponibles en réanimation et permettre
à nos soignants de reconstituer leurs
forces
le lundi 11 mai ne sera possible que si
nous continuons d'être civique
responsable de respecter les règles et
que si la propagation du virus a
effectivement continuer à ralentir
je mesure pleinement en vous le 10 ans
l'effort que je vous demande durant les
quatre semaines à venir les règles
prévues par le gouvernement devront
continuer d'être respecté elles sont en
train de montrer leur efficacité et ne
doivent être ni renforcé ni allégé mais
pleinement appliquée je demande à tous
nos élus dont je sais l'importance dans
cette période
je demande à tous nos élus comme la
république le prévoit en cette matière
d'aidé à ce que ces règles soient les
mêmes partout sur notre sol des
couvre-feux ont été décidés là où
c'était utile mais il ne faut pas
rajouter des interdits dans la journée
pour notre vie quotidienne
il faut continuer lorsque nous sortons à
appliquer les gestes barrière nous tenir
à distance et nous laver les mains je
veux aussi vous rappeler que tous ceux
qui ont une maladie chronique ou
souffrent d'autres maladies doivent
pouvoir continuer à consulter leur
médecin
car il n'y a pas que le virus qui tue
l'extrême solitude le renoncement à
d'autres soins peuvent être aussi
dangereux je souhaite aussi que les
hôpitaux et les maisons de retraite
puisse permettre d'organiser pour les
plus proches avec les bonnes protections
la visite aux malades en fin de vie afin
de pouvoir leur dire adieu
durant cette phase de confinement
le pays continue à vivre
et heureusement certaines activités sont
interdites car incompatible avec les
règles sanitaires
pour tous les autres secteurs
économiques
quant la sécurité des travailleurs et
des entrepreneurs est bien garantie
ils doivent pouvoir produire et l'ont
largement fait depuis maintenant un mois
pour eux tous ceux qui doivent être
aidés durant cette période les mesures
de chômage partiel pour les salariés et
de financement pour les entreprises
seront prolongées et renforcées elles
sont inédites et protège d'ores et déjà
plus de 8 millions de nos salariés et
nombre de nos entreprises pour les
artisans les commerçants les professions
libérales et les entrepreneurs
le fonds de solidarité apporte une
première réponse mais je sais votre
angoisse je les ai entendus je les lui
les charges qui continuent de tomber les
traite les loyers les emprunts c'est
pourquoi j'ai demandé au gouvernement
d'accroître fortement les aides de les
simplifier pour vous permettre de
surmonter cette période
je souhaite que les banques puissent
décalé toutes les échéances beaucoup
plus massivement qu'elles ne l'ont fait
et les assurances doivent être au
rendez-vous de cette mobilisation
économique j'y serai attentif il ya donc
un travail dans les prochains jours à
poursuivre pour vous consolidez
économiquement dans cette période
rapidement un plan spécifique sera mise
en oeuvre pour les secteurs qui comme le
tourisme l'hôtellerie la restauration la
culture et l'événementiel seront
durablement affecté des annulations de
charges et des aides spécifiques seront
mises en place pour les plus fragiles et
les plus démunis ces semaines sont aussi
très difficile
je veux remercier les maires les élus
locaux les associations qui se sont
fortement mobilisés aux côtés du
gouvernement et j'ai demandé à celui-ci
d'aller plus loin là aussi est de verser
sans délai une aide exceptionnelle aux
familles les plus modestes avec des
enfants afin de leur permettre de faire
face à leurs besoins essentiels
les étudiants les plus précaires vivent
parfois loin de leur famille en
particulier lorsque celles ci viennent
d'outre-mer seront aussi aider dès
mercredi le conseil des ministres
décidera des moyens financiers nouveaux
et le gouvernement apportera toutes les
réponses nécessaires à chaque fois qu'il
le faudra
le 11 mai prochain
mes chers compatriotes sera donc le
début d'une nouvelle étape
elle sera progressive les règles
pourront être adaptées en fonction de
nos résultats car l'objectif premier
demeure la santé de tous les français à
partir du 11 mai nous rouvrirons
progressivement les crèches les écoles
les collèges et les lycées
c'est pour moi une priorité car la
situation actuelle creuse des inégalités
trop d'enfants notamment dans les
quartiers populaires dans nos campagnes
sont privés d'école sans avoir accès au
numérique et ne peuvent être aidés de la
même manière par les parents dans cette
période les inégalités de logements les
inégalités entre familles sont encore
plus marqués c'est pourquoi nos enfants
doivent pouvoir retrouver le chemin des
classes
le gouvernement dans la concertation
aura à aménager des règles particulières
organisée différemment le temps et
l'espace
bien protégé nos enseignants et nos
enfants avec le matériel nécessaire pour
les étudiants de l'enseignement
supérieur les cours ne reprendront pas
physiquement jusqu'à l'été
le gouvernement précisera pour chacun la
bonne organisation qui sera nécessaire
en particulier pour les examens et les
concours
le 11 mai il s'agira aussi de permettre
au plus grand nombre de retourner
travailler redémarrer notre industrie
nos commerces et nos services
le gouvernement préparera sans délai ces
réouvertures avec les partenaires
sociaux pour que des règles soient
établies afin de protéger les salariés
au travail
c'est la priorité les lieux rassemblant
du public restaurants cafés des hôtels
cinémas théâtres salles de spectacles et
musées resteront en revanche fermée à ce
stade les grands festivals et événements
avec un public nombreux ne pourront se
tenir au moins jusqu'à mi juillet
prochain la situation sera
collectivement évaluer à partir de mi
mai chaque semaine pour adapter les
choses et vous donner de la visibilité
pour leur protection
nous demanderons aux personnes les plus
vulnérables aux personnes âgées en
situation de handicap sévère aux
personnes atteintes de maladies
chroniques de rester même après le 11
mai confiné tout au moins dans un
premier temps je sais que c'est une
contrainte forte
je mesure ce que je vous demande et nous
allons d'ici le 11 mai travailler à
rendre ce temple supportable pour vous
mais il faudra essayer de s'y tenir pour
vous protéger pour votre intérêt nous
aurons à partir du 11 mai une
organisation nouvelle pour réussir cette
étape
l'utilisation la plus large possible des
tests et la détection est une arme
privilégiée pour sortir au bon moment du
confinement
d'ici là et dans les prochaines semaines
nous allons continuer d'augmenter le
nombre de tests faits chaque jour ses
skis depuis quinze jours et fait durant
les semaines à venir j'ai demandé que
ces tests soient d'abord pratiqué sur
nos aînés nos soignants et les plus
fragiles
et que nous puissions continuer de
mobiliser partout tous les moyens de
faire des tests c'est à dire tous les
laboratoires publics et tous les
laboratoires privés
le 11 mai nous serons en capacité de
tester toute personne présentant des
symptômes n'allons pas testé toutes les
françaises et tous les français
ça n'aurait aucun sens mais toute
personne ayant un symptôme doit pouvoir
être testé les personnes ayant le virus
pourront ainsi être mises en quarantaine
prises en charge et suivi par un médecin
pour accompagner cette phase
plusieurs innovations font l'objet de
travaux avec certains de nos partenaires
européens comme une application
numérique dédié qui sur la base du
volontariat et de l'anonymat permettra
de savoir si oui ou non on s'est trouvé
en contact avec une personne contaminée
vous en avez sûrement entendu parler
le gouvernement aura y travailler il ne
faut négliger aucune piste aucune
innovation mais je souhaite qu'avant le
11 mai nous a semblé puisse en débattre
et que les autorités compétentes puisse
nous éclairer car cette épidémie ne
saurait affaiblir notre démocratie ni
mordre sur quelques libertés
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
nos frontières avec les pays non
européens resteront fermés nous
déploierons ensuite tous les moyens
nécessaires à la protection de la
population
en complément des gestes barrières que
vous connaissez bien et qu'il vous
faudra continuer à appliquer l'état à
partir du 11 mai en lien avec les maires
devra permettre à chaque français de se
procurer un masque grand public pour les
professions les plus exposés et pour
certaines situations comme dans les
transports en commun son usage pourra
devenir systématique
ce sera possible grâce à nos
importations et grâce à la formidable
mobilisation d'entrepreneurs et de
salariés
partout sur le territoire pour produire
massivement ce type de masque le
gouvernement présentera d'ici quinze
jours sur la base de ces principes le
plan de l'après 11 mai et les détails
d'organisation de notre vie quotidienne
des points de rendez vous réguliers se
tiendront pour que nous puissions
adapter les mesures prises et ensemble
décidé de manière régulière d'ajuster
les choses alors à quelle échéance dès
lors peut-on espérer entrevoir la fin
définitive de cette épreuve
quand pourrons-nous renouer avec la vie
d'avant je sais vos questionnements je
les partage
ils sont légitimes j'aimerais tellement
pouvoir tout vous dire et vous répondre
sur chacune de ces questions mais en
toute franchise en toute humilité
nous n'avons pas de réponse définitive à
cela aujourd'hui
dap et d'après les premières données qui
seront prochainement affinée par ce
qu'on appelle les tests sérologiques une
très faible minorité de français ont
contracté le corps est de 19
ce qui veut dire que nous sommes loin de
ce que les spécialistes appellent
l'immunité collective c'est à dire ce
moment où le virus
arrête de lui même sa circulation parce
que suffisamment d'entre nous l'avons vu
c'est pourquoi la première voie pour
sortir de l'épidémie et celle des
vaccins
tout ce que le monde compte de talent de
chercheurs y travaillent
la france est reconnue en la matière et
à d'excellentes ressources parce que
c'est sans doute la solution la plus
sûre même s'il faudra plusieurs mois au
moins pour la mettre en oeuvre notre
pays investira encore plus massivement
dans la recherche et je porterai dans
les prochains jours une initiative avec
nombre de nos partenaires en votre nom
pour accélérer les travaux
la seconde voie ce sont les traitements
nous y travaillons depuis le premier
jour il ya eu je le sais beaucoup de
débats dans le pays toutes les options
sont explorées et notre pays est celui
qui a engagé le plus d'essais cliniques
en europe
j'ai tenu moi même à comprendre chacune
des options possibles à m'assurer que
tout était essayé dans les meilleurs
délais et avec rigueur
il ne s'agit pas de donner un traitement
si on n'est pas sûr mais de procéder à
tous les essais cliniques pour que
toutes les pistes soient poursuivis et
croyez le nos médecins nos chercheurs
travaillent d'arrache-pied aucune piste
n'est à négliger aucune piste ne sera
négligé je m'y engage
voilà ce soir je partage avec vous ce
que nous savons et ce que nous ne savons
pas nous finiront par l'emporter mais
nous aurons plusieurs mois à vivre avec
le virus avec humilité il nous faut
aujourd'hui décider et agir en tenant
compte des incertitudes avec lucidité
oui parce que regarder l'asie le virus
semblait avoir été vaincus et il revient
dans de nombreux pays qui à nouveau
décidé de refermer leurs économies il
nous faut donc procéder avec calme et
courage
mais ce que je sais ce que je sais à ce
moment mes chers compatriotes c'est que
notre nation se tient debout solidaire
dans un but commun on disait que nous
étions un peuple
indisciplinés et voilà que nous
respectons des règles des disciplines
parmi les plus rigoureuses jamais imposé
à notre peuple en temps de paix on
disait que nous étions un peuple épuisé
routinier bien loin de l'élan des
fondations et voilà que tant d'entre
vous rivalisent de dévouement
d'engagement face à l'inattendu de cette
menace nous voilà tous solidaire
fraternelle unis concitoyens d'un pays
qui fait face concitoyens d'un pays qui
débat qui discutent qui continuent de
vivre sa musique démocratique mais qui
restent unis je veux ce soir partager
avec vous au coeur de l'épreuve
cette fierté cette certaine idée qui a
fait la france est bien là vivante et
créatrice et cela doit nous remplir
d'espoir c'est nous durant les semaines
à venir le gouvernement le parlement
notre administration avec nos mères et
nos élus locaux auront à préparer la
suite
pour ce qui me concerne je tâcherai de
porter en europe
notre voie afin d'avoir plus d'unité de
solidarité
les premières décisions ont été dans le
bon sens et nous avons beaucoup poussé
pour cela qu'il s'agisse de la banque
centrale européenne de la commission
européenne ou des gouvernements mais
nous sommes à un moment de vérité qui
impose plus d'ambition plus d'audace un
moment de re fondation
nous devons aussi savoir aider nos
voisins d'afrique à lutter contre le
virus plus efficacement à les aider
aussi sur le plan économique en annulant
massivement leurs dettes
oui
une gagneront jamais seul parce
qu'aujourd'hui à bergame madrid
bruxelles londres pékin new york
alger ou dakar nous pleurons les morts
d'un même virus alors si notre monde
sans doute se fragmentera il est de
notre responsabilité de bâtir dès
aujourd'hui des solidarités et des
coopérations nouvelle il nous reviendra
aussi dans les prochaines semaines de
préparer l'après il nous faudra rebâtir
notre économie plus forte afin de
produire et redonner plein espoir à nos
salariés et nos entrepreneurs garder
notre indépendance financière
il nous faudra rebâtir une indépendance
agricole sanitaire industrielles et
technologiques françaises et plus
d'autonomie stratégique pour notre
europe
cela passera par un plan massif pour
notre santé notre recherche nos aînés
entre autres il nous faudra nous
rappeler aussi que notre pays
aujourd'hui tient tout entier sur des
femmes et des hommes que nos économies
reconnaissent et rémunère si mal
les distinctions sociales ne peuvent
être fondées que sur l'utilité commune
ces mots les français les ont écrits il
y a plus de 200 ans devons aujourd'hui
reprendre le flambeau et donner toute sa
force à ce principe
il nous faudra bâtir
une stratégie où nous retrouverons le
temps long la possibilité de planifier
la sobriété carbone la prévention la
résilience qui seuls peuvent permettre
de faire face aux crises à venir
ces quelques évidences s'imposent
aujourd'hui à nous mais ne suffiront pas
et je revis je reviendrai donc vers vous
pour parler de cet après le moment que
nous vivons est un ébranlement intime et
collectif sachons le vivre comme tel il
nous rappelle que nous sommes
vulnérables
l'avion sans doute oublié et ne
cherchons pas à tout de suite
il trouvait la confirmation de ce en
quoi nous avions toujours cru non
sachons dans ce moment sortir des
sentiers battus des idéologies et nous
réinventer moi le premier
il ya dans cette crise une chance nous
ressouder et prouver notre humanité
bâtir un autre projet dans la concorde
un projet français une raison de vivre
ensemble profonde
dans les prochaines semaines avec toutes
les composantes de notre nation je
tâcherai de dessiner ce chemin qui rend
cela possible
mes chers compatriotes nous aurons des
jours meilleurs et nous retrouverons les
jours heureux j'en ai la conviction et
les vertus qui aujourd'hui nous
permettent de tenir seront celles qui
nous aideront à bâtir l'avenir notre
solidarité notre confiance
notre volonté alors prenez soin de vous
prenons soin les uns des autres et nous
tiendrons
vive la république vive la france
la 27 minutes d'allocution du président
macron va aller tout de suite retrouvé
tomas bonnet qui se trouve devant
l'elysée thomas que doit-on retenir de
ce long discours à des manuels microns
ce qu'on retiendra c'est évidemment
cette date le 11 mai date annoncée de la
fin de confinement date annoncée par le
président de la république a affirmé que
le consul man le plus strict l'épée le
seul moyen d'agir efficacement contre
cette épidémie
il ne faut ni renforcé ni alléger les
mesures de confinement ce sont les mots
du président de la république alors
concernant le 11 mai il a parlé d'une
réouverture progressive des différents
établissements scolaires je propose
d'écouter le président a admis qu à
partir du 11 mai nous rouvrirons
progressivement les crèches les écoles
les collèges et les lycées
c'est pour moi une priorité car la
situation actuelle creuse des inégalités
trop d'enfants notamment dans les
quartiers populaires dans nos campagnes
sont privés d'école sans avoir accès au
numérique et ne peuvent être aidés de la
même manière par les parents dans cette
période les inégalités de logements les
inégalités entre familles sont encore
plus marqués c'est pourquoi nos enfants
doivent pouvoir retrouver le chemin des
classes
le gouvernement dans la concertation
aura à aménager des règles particulières
organisée différemment le temps et
l'espace
bien protégé nos enseignants et nos
enfants avec le matériel nécessaire pour
les étudiants de l'enseignement
supérieur les cours ne reprendront pas
physiquement jusqu'à l'été le
gouvernement précisera pour chacun la
bonne organisation qui sera nécessaire
en particulier pour les examens et les
cons
le président l'a public a également
affirmé que le lundi 11 mai pourrait
signifier le retour au travail d'un
certain nombre de français en revanche
pas de réouverture pour ce qui concerne
les restaurants ou encore les cinémas et
puis il a émis également l'hypothèse que
les personnes les plus vulnérables les
personnes âgées les personnes malades
puissent rester en confirmant un peu
plus longtemps au delà donc de cette das
date du 11 mai le président de l'acdic
également fait un point sur les ratés
cessons ces sonos les ratés qui ont
connu le début de cette épidémie pas
assez préparés à cette crise avec pas
assez de matériel c'est une question qui
est évidemment revenu beaucoup ces
derniers temps at on les moyens de
combattre cette épidémie il ya la
question des masques il ya également la
question des tests et là dessus le
président de la république s'est
prononcé
nous aurons à partir du 11 mai une
organisation nouvelle pour réussir cette
étape
l'utilisation la plus large possible des
tests et la détection est une arme
privilégiée pour sortir au bon moment du
confinement
d'ici là et dans les prochaines semaines
nous allons continuer d'augmenter le
nombre de tests faits chaque jour ses
skis depuis quinze jours et fait durant
les semaines à venir j'ai demandé que
ces tests soient d'abord pratiqué sur
nos aînés nos soignants et les plus
fragiles et que nous puissions continuer
de mobiliser partout tous les moyens de
faire des tests c'est à dire tous les
laboratoires publics et tous les
laboratoires privés
le 11 mai nous serons en capacité de
tester toute personne présentant des
symptômes n'allons pas testé toutes les
françaises et tous les français
ça n'aurait aucun sens mais toute
personne ayant un symptôme doit pouvoir
être testé les personnes ayant le virus
pourront ainsi être mises en quarantaine
prises en charge et suivi par un médecin
pour accompagner cette phase plusieurs
innovations font l'objet de travaux avec
certains de nos partenaires européens
comme une application numérique dédié
qui sur la base du volontariat et de
l'anonymat permettra de savoir si oui ou
non on s'est trouvé en contact avec une
personne contaminée
vous en avez sûrement entendu parler
le gouvernement aura y travailler il ne
faut négliger aucune piste aucune
innovation mais je souhaite qu'avant le
11 mai nous a semblé puisse en débattre
et que les autorités compétentes puisse
nous éclairer
car cette épidémie ne saurait affaiblir
notre démocratie ni mordre sur quelques
libertés
parmi les autres annonces du président
de la république il ya donc cette
promesse d' accroître les aides aux
entreprises encore d'aider les familles
les plus modestes avec des enfants ainsi
que les étudiants précaires le président
de la république qui a fait preuve
d'humilité nous n'avons pas les réponses
à toutes les questions et c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles les contours de ce
déconfinement pourront continuer à se
redessiner dans les prochaines semaines
avant donc cette date annoncée ce soir
par le président a tout dit la date du
lundi 11 mai jour donc d'être en finale
merci thomas bonne effectivement le 11
mai un plan sera à ce moment là selon
emmanuel macron présenté par le
gouvernement plusieurs réactions
évidemment vont se multiplier ces
prochaines minutes parmi eux
celle de nicolas dupont aignan président
de debout la france avec lequel nous
sommes en direct bonsoir nicolas dupont
aignan merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors avant l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron vous disiez souhaité
un changement de cap est ce que vous
êtes satisfait ce soir
écoutez je suis un peu inquiet très
franchement parce que oui il faut un
déconfinement progressif mais je ne
comprends pas du tout comment on va
réaliser à des confirmands progressif en
rouvrant toutes les écoles d'un coup
cela me paraît extrêmement dangereux oui
à des compliments progressif oui un mois
de plus pour qu'on ait des masses les
tests mais tous les pays qui ont laissé
reprendre le travail progressivement
n'ont pas rouvert toutes les écoles d'un
coup parce que vous comprenez bien que
mettre tous les élèves d'un cours dans
les établissements cela peut entraîner
bien évidemment la diffusion d'épidémie
partout dans toutes les familles donc
oui à l'idée du déconfinement progressif
oui à l'idée qu'il faut en sortir
mais attention de grâce qu'il y a un
plan précis et le déconfinement ne peut
avoir lieu que quand les personnes qui
sortent et qui retravaille dispose d'un
mas et sont testés j'ajoute dernier
point que j'ai été stupéfait d'entendre
le président de la république refuse et
toujours le contrôle des frontières
nationales qui est la base de tout car
on ne pourra dès confiner le pays que si
on contrôle bien nos frontières
nationales ce que font la plupart des
pays du monde mais que se refuse à faire
par idéologie président de la république
dernier point de frustration
il a parlé des masques et des textes
mais il ya rien de précis encore
donc tout va dépendre de la capacité de
l'industrie nationale à produire ces
masques et ces tests et tout va dépendre
bien évidemment aussi des traitements et
je regrette que le président n'ait pas
autorisé les médecins à retrouver leur
liberté de prescription pour notamment
pouvoir prescrire le traitement du
professeur raoul qui est autorisé en
italie aux états unis en israël
maroc en algérie et que je passe voilà
donc je dirais enfin on a un horizon
faut être franc c'est le bon côté de la
locution en revanche je crains le
dérapage incontrôlé le 11 mai sic on a
avancé sur les masques et les tests et
si on en voit tous les enfants dans les
écoles sans aucune précaution
nicolas dupont aignan justement vous
soulignez que les enfants sont renvoyés
dans les écoles ça se fera un petit peu
selon vous en tout cas du jour en main
pas de déconfinement partiel selon vous
quelle est l'arrière pensée si on a une
des manuels micron c'est peut-être
favoriser l'économie permettent
peut-être aux parents de retourner
travailler parce que si nous faisons les
enfants à la maison ils ne pourront pas
l'être
emmanuel macron a fait ce soir on vous
le choix de l'économie ne croît qu'il a
fait le choix oui de l'économie à tout
prix avec un délai d'un mois qui me
paraît qui me paraîtrait tout à fait
acceptable si on avait un gouvernement
qui avait prévu les choses mais on est
dans une débâcle en termes de production
nationale en termes de tests en termes
eu de médicaments donc toute la question
et moi je suis pas au pouvoir je ne suis
pas à sa place
mais est-ce qu'en annonçant sa il est
sûr d'avoir les masses les tester ce qui
m'a inquiété c'est qu'il dit le 11 mai
on testera les gens qui ont des
symptômes mais c'est pas ça c'est qu'il
faudrait tester les gens qui vont
retourner travailler pas ce qu ont des
symptômes puisqu'on le sait très bien il
faut tester en amont donc eu encore une
fois toute la question
moi j'ai pas la réponse 1 je veux pas
faire de procès d'intention à l'avance
parce que si le président est sûre de
son gouvernement est sûr d'avoir la
milliards de masse pour femmes est bon
qu'on met au public nous dit emmanuel
macron c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à à
savoir vraiment ce qu'est un masque ou
grand public
moi ce qui m'inquiète si vous voulez
c'est quand on voit l'état d'amateurisme
du gouvernement depuis un deux mois et
notamment qu'on n'arrive toujours pas à
voir le chiffre précis des masques à
porter on sait que la production
nationale est insuffisante
moi je lave réclament la réquisition du
sinn bon le gouvernement s'y refuse
entre nous
donc on aa les 25% 30% des besoins qui
sont fabriqués par une production
nationale tout le reste dépend des
importations donc la seule question qui
se pose c'est si on continue au rythme
actuel de 20 millions par semaine au 25
millions par semaine une en chine ça
suffira pas donc moi je suis pas en
position simplement le point faible du
discours de ce soir c'est les écoles
ouvertes dès le 11 mai qui me paraît
complètement dément en l'absence d'une
vraie précaution maintenant que l'on
reprenne progressivement le
déconfinement à partir du 11 mai cela me
paraît raisonnable si on a les masses
pour ceux qui vont travailler donc vous
le voyez c'est une course contre la
montre est ce que le président de la
république après nous avoir dit d'aller
au théâtre le 7 mars d'aller voter le 15
mars puis nous enfermer est ce que le
président de la république est un homme
sérieux où il continue son baratin
permanent son théâtre en nous emmenant
encore une fois dans le mur
j'ose espérer qu'il a bien calculé son
risque et j'ose espérer que le
gouvernement va enfin agir mais peu
comprenez que je sois encore un peu
inquiet attention toutes les chances de
nicolas dupont aignan strict qui vous
ont au contraire fait plaisir une
autonomie stratégique pour l'europe
apprenent emmanuel macron un moment de
refondation pour l'union européenne des
frontières de schengen alors à défaut de
la france ça on a bien compris que
c'était votre souhait qui resteront
fermés jusqu'à nouvel ordre ce sont des
bonnes mesures ce soir et c'est du
baratin
c'est du baratin complet moi je veux une
autonomie stratégique pour la france
je veux des frontières pour la france je
veux de l'indépendance pour la france ça
veut rien dire tout ça e
d'ailleurs c'est pas ce qu'on crée les
problèmes qui vont les résoudre
donc qui peut faire confiance à emmanuel
macron lui qui a bradé le pays pendant
des années comme ministre puis comme
président pour faire tout cela
ça c'est du discours électoral pour à
mater les électeurs mais personne n'y
croit donc ne débattons pas de ça les
français choisiront celui ou celle qui
sera le plus à même d'assurer
l'indépendance du pays le moment venu
qui peut croire un instant que cet homme
qui a tout brader qui nous a pas préparé
soit capable de faire cela et puis rang
en l'occurrence
l'enjeu c'est pas l'indépendance de
l'europe oui à terme mais déjà il
faudrait que la france connaisse ses
propres moyens
et quand on voit l'allemagne qui a trait
juste raison a d'abord défendu l'intérêt
de l'allemagne est aujourd'hui à 5 4
fois moins de morts donc oui l'europe
très bien mais l'europe c'est l'addition
de volonté nationale et moi j'aimerais
que le président parle de l'indépendance
stratégique de la france
et ici on avait cette indépendance
stratégique aujourd'hui on courait pas
après les masses
après les tests après les médicaments
donc eu là c'est du baratin comme
d'habitude personne n'y croit en tout
cas pas moi et je crois que l'enjeu
c'est qu'on sorte du confinement avec
les masses les tests et un traitement ça
c'est donc et là dessus j'attends des
chiffres précis du gouvernement pour
voir si le scénario du président est
réaliste ou si encore il nous vend du
vent merci beaucoup à nicolas dupont
aignan président de debout à la france
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour réagir donc à ce discours d'
emmanuel macron et on reste dans les
réactions ce soir nous sommes maintenant
on direct avec danièle obono aux députés
la france insoumise de la 17ème
circonscription de parry bonsoir danièle
obono merci d'être avec nous votre
réaction à ce discours d' emmanuel
macron ce soir écoutez c'est un discours
qui a donné une date
donc c'est un horizon une perspective de
sortie du confinement mais n'a pas
vraiment explicite et les moyens qui
étaient prévus et la quantité de moyens
qu'il faudrait pour pouvoir réaliser ce
déconfinement on se pose encore plus de
questions de mon point de vue et nous
aurons beaucoup de questions à poser aux
gouvernements et des propositions à
faire sur la manière dont nous pensons
qu'il est nécessaire d'organiser la
production de la planifier pour être en
capacité de procéder à un déconfinement
qui ne peut être de notre point de vue
que progressif et ciblé parce que en
l'état étant donné les retards qui ont
été pris pour prendre
les mesures de protection étant données
y compris la manière dont le confinement
actuelle est organisée c'est à dire
qu'il ya malgré ce qu'a dit le président
qui parlait d'un confinement strict il y
a beaucoup de secteurs non essentiels
qui sont encore en activité que le
gouvernement a poussé à continuer à être
en activité sans que les salariés de ces
secteurs soient suffisamment protégé il
y a au niveau de la santé il l'a reconnu
d'ailleurs le président beaucoup de
soignants et soignante qui n'ont même
pas encore les moyens de protection donc
déjà en confinement il y as on voit bien
des problèmes en terme de production de
tests suffisant production de masques et
de l'ensemble des matériels de
protection donc de notre point de vue
d'une certaine manière le gouvernement
prend là peut-être encore les choses à
l'envers
il s'agit de déterminer quels sont les
besoins pour pouvoir protéger l'ensemble
de la population
et ensuite comment est-ce qu'on organise
la production la société pour le faire
donc il y à une date encore une fois un
11 mai et on va voir un peu c'est un
rétroplanning qui qui qui est présentée
puisque nous aurons cette fin de semaine
à l'assemblée des premiers éléments de
2,2 de moyens financiers est ce que par
exemple le gouvernement va enfin accéder
à notre proposition de réinstituer sion
de liesse pour permettre de mettre en
oeuvre la production suffisante
est-ce qu'il va accéder à notre
proposition de réquisition d'un certain
nombre d'industries notamment
l'industrie textile pour pouvoir
produire autant de max que possible au
niveau national localement et pas
simplement attendre les importations
dont on sait que le marché est saturé et
un extrêmement attention donc voila nous
on a un certain nombre de questions
assez précises au delà de cette date qui
est importante encore une fois c'est
vrai que le confinement pèse notamment
aux secteurs les plus vulnérables les
plus précaires de la population mais je
pense plus largement
il ya beaucoup de souffrances et de
difficultés physiques émotionnels
psychologiques dans cette période est
donc il me semble que cette cette
intervention
au delà de la date du 11 mai manqué et
manque de précision et j'espère en tous
les cas que le président et son
gouvernement vont cette fois privilégier
la protection sanitaire de la population
et non l'économie puisque c'est bien une
des raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
rentrés tardivement confinement parce
que il y avait ce primat de de
l'économie d'activité économique c'est
aussi pour ça que certains secteurs sont
encore en activité parce qu'il faut
privilégier l'activité économique
donc nous allons être vigilants pour
cette ces prochaines semaines et ces
prochaines phases pour que avant tout
c'est la santé de la population son
bien-être physique son bien-être social
qui prime sur sur la volonté de profit à
tout prix
danièle obono ont assisté un petit mea
culpa si j'ose dire des manuels macron
qui a commencé par dire à l'évidence la
france n'était pas prête il a terminé
également par voilà un discours un peu
plus lyrique sachons nous réinventer moi
le premier ça veut dire selon vous que
le président de la république a été
changée par cette épreuve et va
peut-être assouplir sa politique
notamment envers les personnes peut-être
les plus défavorisés ce qu'on lui a
souvent reproché un côté trop libérale
est ce qui va changer selon vous je ne
le crois pas franchement surtout les
premiers à appuyer une véritable
réorientation c'est ce que nous avons
dit y compris dès le départ que ces
crises signé l'échec de l'ensemble des
politiques néolibérales anti social et
anti écologique qui ont été menées ces
dernières années et notamment par
emmanuel macro qui est dans
l'institution au pouvoir depuis des
années et qu'il fallait
maintenant dans la manière dont nous
mettions en oeuvre y compris la
planification y compris l'organisation
et la mise en action de la société il
fallait dès maintenant aurait orientés
bifurquer faire en sorte par exemple que
l'enjeu écologique ne passe pas à la
trappe par volonté absolue de faire
repartir l'économie et du coup de faire
repartir sur des bases productiviste et
cetera
mais justement ce que fait aujourd'hui
le gouvernement ça montre précisément
qu'il n'a toujours pas retenu la leçon
des raisons pour lesquelles nous sommes
dans une crise sanitaire et économique
notamment l'état des services publics
hospitaliers et on le voit comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure avec la volonté de
faire travailler à tout prix des
secteurs non essentiels qui ne servent
ni à apporter des moyens pour le soin
des personnes ou à la prévention et à
l'alimentation et les secteurs
essentiels
on le voit avec les discours qui appelle
à faire des efforts mais pas de tout le
monde et certainement pas des plus
riches
et puis on le voit avec la manière dont
on ignore le fait d'en sur sur le
terrain c'est avant tout la
stigmatisation et une politique plus de
répression et de et 2 et 2 et
sécuritaire qui est mise en oeuvre
pourquoi il faut je crois rester
mobilisés et et préparés nous mêmes dès
maintenant l'alternative le président en
aura compris les messages merci danièle
obono en tout cas d'avoir réagi en
direct sur arte france on va ré écouter
l'un des moments certainement clé de ce
discours emmanuel macron qui est donc
annoncé la réouverture des écoles
collèges et lycées d
11 mai prochain à écouter à partir du 11
mai nous rouvrirons progressivement les
crèches les écoles les collèges et les
lycées
c'est pour moi une priorité car la
situation actuelle creuse des inégalités
trop d'enfants notamment dans les
quartiers populaires dans nos campagnes
sont privés d'école sans avoir accès au
numérique et ne peuvent être aidés de la
même manière par les parents dans cette
période les inégalités de logements les
inégalités entre familles sont encore
plus marqués c'est pourquoi nos enfants
doivent pouvoir retrouver le chemin des
classes
le gouvernement dans la concertation
aura à aménager des règles particulières
organisée différemment le temps et
l'espace
bien protégé nos enseignants et nos
enfants avec le matériel nécessaire pour
les étudiants de l'enseignement
supérieur les cours ne reprendront pas
physiquement jusqu'à l'été le
gouvernement précisera pour chacun la
bonne organisation qui sera nécessaire
en particulier pour les examens et les
concours
et voilà donc pour ce moment important
nous sommes en direct avec anja style
député non-inscrit de la 2e
circonscription de l'oise bonsoir anne y
est-il merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france voulez vous faire écouter
justement ce passage parce qu'il se
trouve que outre le fait des députés
vous êtes également directrice d'école
pour vous c'est une bonne chose
retour le 11 mai on n'est pas vraiment
dans un déconfinement partiel cela va
assez vite
tout va se passer le 11 mai à en croire
le président de la république
bonsoir toutouba visiblement pas que
passé le 11 mai mais j'aimerais jouer
s'il est beaucoup trop doué mais je me
réjouis c'est les élèves peuvent
retourner et peuvent retrouver le chemin
des écoles il faut savoir que dans
l'oise nous ça fait plus que plus de six
semaines que des enfants sont chez eux
et et ça peut pas durer c'est c'est
difficile clairement au moins les
familles s'aperçoivent quatre
enseignants c'est un vrai métier mais
c'est compliqué
tous sont censés être en télétravail et
c'est difficile les enfants doivent
vivre avec leurs terres et grandir avec
leur père avoir des interactions
voilà en tout cas je salue immédiatement
le faire les enseignants qui se sont mis
immédiatement aux échanges numériques
avec leurs propres outils avec leurs
outils personnels et sans y être préparé
il faut bien reconnaître et s'y sont mis
vraiment avec les parents avec les
élèves
on voit des classes virtuelles en poids
on voit les interactions vraiment je les
félicite parce que parce que je sais que
qu'il s'agit de leur matériel personnel
qui ne sont pas tous trek en campagne on
n'a pas forcément la fibre ou aux
troubles ou internet et est vraiment je
les félicite
maintenant effectivement il faut pas que
ça dure trop pour les enfants clairement
nicolas dupont aignan notre invité
précédent nous faisait part de ses
craintes
de ceux des confinement qui pour lui
n'est pas vraiment partiel parce que
c'est vrai que en croire le président de
la république a parlé personnes âgées
tout le monde semblera être des confiné
à partir de cette date vous fait
confiance on emmanuel macron quand il
dit voilà il y aura des masques grand
public pour tout le monde
les personnes qui souhaiteront est testé
pourront le faire alors sachant que ce
ne sont pas des tests sérologiques ce
sont des tests de dépistage du virus
uniquement destiné aux personnes qui ont
des symptômes est ce que cela est
suffisant selon vous alors je sais ce
que je fais confiance le dire on gagne à
faire confiance à l'autre mais mais mais
moi en même temps me gêne c'est vrai
parce que j'ai entendu l'espoir renaît
mais rien est acquis
donc c'est vrai rekik il faut pas dire
non plus que l'espagne n'aurait pas mais
mais c'est en même temps me gêne parce
que par exemple je trouve que le
déconfinement n'est pas n'est pas
toujours bien bien respectée à paris ou
dans les grandes villes
et voilà je connais des gens qui
travaillent en hôpitaux et qui sont très
en colère de voir les gens dans la rue
et le moins certains m'ont dit fond au
lieu de leur donner des amendes et il
faudrait leur faire nettoyer l'hôpital
pour qu'il voie les gens mourir oui
mourir et voilà parfois je ne sais pas
si on se rend bien compte de ce qui
fâche
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on est dans dans
une véritable de crise qui frappe à
celle de 2008 au niveau des des
entreprises et aux trains de 2003 va
dans l'oise on est très très ennuyée
vous disiez que le 11 mai tout le monde
reprenait c'est pas vrai alors j'aime à
dire ça mais c'est vrai qu'il y aura un
plan de 11 mai à 1 déconfinement le fait
que les enfants aillent à l'école
effectivement ça veut dire souvent que
les transports reprennent que l'économie
en quelque sorte reprend donc il y aura
effectivement beaucoup de choses qui
vont se passer à ce moment là un plan
après on lui est d'ailleurs présentée
par le gouvernement c'est vraiment une
date clé a manifestement oui et des
pâtes et les parents pourront sûrement
retrouver à le retourner à leur travail
mais il faut être prudent enfin je j'ai
vraiment envie de raison garder
le virus n'est pas guéri
et on n'a pas les médicaments n'a pas
les vaccins royal c'est aujourd'hui
voilà ce qui est prévu mais j'ai envie
de dire nous sommes quand même un peu au
jour le jour
imaginons qu'il y aille heureux qu'il
n'y ait une rechute une repique jus qui
lie à nouveau beaucoup de cas je ne sais
pas si celle ci se sera pas prononcé
voilà normalement c'est ainsi si on
continue bien se tait complètement si on
continue bien dans la même voie c'est
ainsi que les choses sont prévues mais
dans une crise comme celle ci vous savez
il faut être très très prudent je pense
qu on peut on peut évidemment toujours
critiquer donc je pense que c'est passé
le plus passer ailleurs de critiquer
critiquer les décisions de ceux qui
agissent ils ont agi dans l'urgence pour
des dizaines de millions de personnes
les dizaines de millions d'entreprises
des dizaines de millions d' activités
dépendantes tous les unes des autres et
qui est qui et qui intègre des milliers
d'inconnus et relevés en permanence
novaes jugé bienvenu dans l'oise vous
savez on mettait des précurseurs deux
semaines avant tout le monde
on ad'abord d'abord un cluster et puis
un autre
kloster et puis les enfants et puis et
puis les séminaires mais on laisse sont
ouverts est-ce qu'on aurait été prêt la
critique est facile mais ce qu on l
aurait été prêt ya trois semaines
d'interdire les manifestations
d'interdire les matchs de te foutent de
l'euro de reporter les élections
aujourd'hui on n'y est plus près on a
peut-être un peu plus conscience de ce
qui se passe bon le lasik ou n'a pas été
rose et j'apprécie je vous avoue le je
vais pas dire le mea culpa mais un peu
de la vérité qui a été dit parce que
parce que oui il ya un problème de
masques et oui on a eu et on gagne à
dire la vérité
au lendement effectivement emmanuel
macron qui a servi que la france à
l'évidence n'était pas assez préparés à
la crise
merci en tout cas nier style député
jeune habitant de la 2e circonscription
de l'oise d'avoir été avec nous pour
réagir à cette allocution de emmanuel
macron et les mesures de chômage partiel
pour les salariés et de financement pour
les entreprises en difficulté seront
prolongées
et renforcé c'est l'un des points
importants effectivement annoncées ce
soir par le chef de l'état écouter
certaines activités sont interdites car
incompatible avec les règles sanitaires
pour tous les autres secteurs
économiques
quant la sécurité des travailleurs et
des entrepreneurs est bien garantie
ils doivent pouvoir produire et l'ont
largement fait depuis maintenant un mois
pour eux tous ceux qui doivent être
aidés durant cette période les mesures
de chômage partiel pour les salariés et
de financement pour les entreprises
seront prolongées et renforcées elles
sont inédites et protège d'ores et déjà
plus de 8 millions de nos salariés et
nombre de nos entreprises pour les
artisans les commerçants les professions
libérales et les entrepreneurs
le fonds de solidarité apporte une
première réponse mais je sais votre
angoisse je les entends du jeu l'élu les
charges qui continuent de tomber les
traite les loyers les emprunts c'est
pourquoi j'ai demandé au gouvernement
d'accroître fortement les aides de les
simplifier pour vous permettre de
surmonter cette période
je souhaite que les banques puissent
décalé toutes les échéances beaucoup
plus massivement qu'elles ne l'ont fait
et les assurances doivent être au
rendez-vous de cette mobilisation
économique j'y serai attentif et voilà
pour ce moment consacré à l'économie on
va justement allé voir la réaction de
françois aux mairies le président de la
cfe cgc bonsoir françois au mérite mais
registre avec nous en direct sur rt
français ce que se disent qu'on vous a
satisfait ce que vous êtes soulagé pour
les entreprises que vous représentez non
personne ne peut être soulagé pour les
entreprises parce que on le sait la
crise va être durable et les très
profonde et va laisser sur le bord de la
route effectivement un certain nombre
d'activités qui sont aujourd'hui très
durement impactée par par la crise
sanitaire qui s'est doublée d'une crise
économique
ceci dit il faut il faut je crois a
rappelé que le
gouvernement a pris une décision majeure
en décidant de financer sans réserves le
chômage partiel de façon à ce que les
compétences restent dans l'entreprise
pour nous pour la cfe cgc c'était une
décision absolument fondamental
effectivement c'est un effort financier
très très important le président de la
république nous annonce que cet effort
va être maintenue bien entendu c'est
être indispensable il faut chaque jour
avoir une mesure un peu plus précise de
l'impact de la crise sur la fia ni terre
bien sûr sur le tissu économique et de
ce qu'il va falloir contribuer à réparer
dans les jours qui viennent ou fur et à
mesure que l'activité reprend car il y a
des signes assez visible du fait que
l'activité par endroits commence à
reprendre mais on comprend aussi dans
l'intervention du président de la
république que sur certains secteurs
ceux qui ont été fermés dès le premier
jour c'est à dire certains commerces les
restaurants l'hôtel tout ce qui touche
au tourisme il ya ça par contre ça n'est
pas prêt de reprendre et on peut on peut
comprendre que pour ces secteurs là la
crise va être extrêmement plus profonde
et plus longue effectivement les cafés
hôtels restaurants les festivals
également qu'ils n'auront pas lieu en
tout cas jusqu'à la mi juillet comment
ces secteurs là selon vous vouliez qui
les connaissez bien peuvent s'en
remettre à ce que l'état justement a les
moyens de subvenir aux milliards dont on
aura besoin pour compenser il ya deux
moyens l'état de toute façon dès
l'instant qu'ils en aient la volonté
peut mobiliser tous les moyens
nécessaires c'est ça la politique la
tendance elle suit toujours c'est un
prince un principe malheureusement qui a
été trop peu oublié ces dernières années
où on a fait précéder une tendance à la
décision politique je vais pas me
plaindre que pour une fois la décision
politique est la presse et des les
préoccupations d'intendant certes il va
y avoir un coût extrêmement important
mais il faut avoir en tête que si ces
décisions là n'avaient pas été prises
le coût social et le coût économique au
final aurait été bien sûr beaucoup plus
important donc s'agissant des secteurs
les plus touchés dans la durée par la
décision de la fermeture les secteurs
durée des restaurants du tourisme et
bien ces secteurs-là ces cas le
gouvernement a mis en place et bien ça
va s'appliquer bien entendu le chômage
partiel dès le premier jour mais ce dont
ces secteurs vont avoir besoin
puisqu'ils ne font plus de chiffre
d'affaires c'est bien sûr d apport de
trésorerie
je dois dire que le secteur bancaire
s'est un peu fait tirer l'oreille au
début mais finalement est un peu rentré
dans l'ordre il ya eu c'est vrai un peu
de difficulté à enclencher le mécanisme
de façon à ce que les facilités
bancaires les facilités de trésorerie
les reports de paiement tout ça s'est
mis en place je crois qu'il faut pas
trop se plaindre
finalement petit à petit la mécanique
s'est enclenchée il ya clairement un
françois-marie pardonnez moi de vous
couper mais les banques sont clairement
invité à décaler leur échéance les
assurances à en faire plus elles ont été
clairement c'était assez bon par
emmanuel macron oui oui il les a cités
et je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
quand il a parlé des banques
il avait encore un peu le sourire quand
il a parlé des assurances il a pris
l'air très très sévère et je pense qu'il
a bien fait parce que ces derniers jours
nous sommes un certain nombre à avoir
fait remonté au plus haut niveau de
l'exécutif certain nombre d'attitudes
que nous trouvons pas tout à fait
remarquable par exemple certaines
assurances dites de notation vous savez
ce qu'ils ont pour métier de côté les
différentes entreprises et qui fait que
suivant la note qu'ils ont eh bien ils
accèdent à des taux d'intérêt plus ou
moins importants sur le marché de la
dette et bien d'apprendre il ya quelques
jours quelques semaines que
certaines sociétés de cotation avait
dégradé les notes des assurances nous on
a trouvé que c'était pour le coup ne pas
jouer très collectif dans cette affaire
je pense que le président de la
république dans sa petite intervention
et ce petit regard sévère qu'il a eue
voulait pointé ceux qui ne jouent pas
très corporate
je crois que dans des situations de
crise à ce point là et bien c'est l'as
et c'est là que les caractère profond se
révèle donc il faudra effectivement le
moment venu après le 11 mai est
probablement bien au delà et bien avoir
l'exacte souvenir des attitudes de
chacun au moment où la solidarité était
absolument nécessaire à tous les niveaux
de l'économie à tous les niveaux de
l'état de l'engagement des individus
emmanuel macron qui a évidemment c'est
vraiment risquer des dates extrêmement
précises avec un confinement sortie de
confinement strict le 11 mai l'école qui
reprend alors c'est vrai que c'était pas
une surprise mais en même temps beaucoup
de nos confrères le figaro le jdd pour
ne citer qu'eux avaient évoqué la
rentrée en septembre est ce que c'est
une bonne chose selon vous évidemment en
termes économiques ça veut dire qu'il y
aura vraiment une reprise d'activité qui
ira sur le président d'acf cg c'est que
nous est écoutée pour tout vous dire
c'est pas forcément le secteur sur
lequel j'ai le moins de compétences un
pur pour m'exprimer mais je crois que
tous on peut dire qu'effectivement que
l'école reprenne est une très bonne
chose
sur tous les plans c'est une bonne chose
parce que là dessus je suis aussi
l'intervention du président de la
république les inégalités qui tout d'un
coup se font jour
dès l'instant que chaque enfant ait
ramené à son voyage à son foyer pour
continuer ses études
eh bien ces inégalités il faut être
extrêmement attentif à ce qu'elles ne se
creusent pas trop longtemps et je pense
que dans la décision qui a été prise
effectivement de faire une reprise
graduée d'abord les écoles et puis après
l'été les universités il ya la prise en
compte de
la fragilité sociale qui lia et qui
petit à petit se dessine de plus en plus
fortement suivant l'âge que l'on a c'est
une je pense une très bonne nouvelle que
l'école puisse reprendre dès le 11 mai
s'il est confirmé effectivement que
l'école reprend ce jour là merci
beaucoup françois au mérite président de
la cfe cgc d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france à 21h05 soyez les
bienvenus si vous nous rejoignez en
direct sur notre antenne emmanuel macron
qui s'est donc exprimé pendant presque
30 minutes depuis l'elysée 27 minutes
précisément le président de la
république a donc annoncé qu'un
déconfinement progressif commencerait à
partir du 11 mai autre déclaration
importante le nombre de tests augmentera
et la france sera en mesure le 11 mai de
tester toute personne présentant des
symptômes on retrouve tout de suite pour
le résumé thomas bonnet pour plus de
détails thomas vous avez donc suivi
cette allocution
qu'est ce que vous en retenez je ne
retiens c'est évidemment la date que
vous venez d'annoncer la date du lundi
11 mai c'est la date jusqu'à laquelle
les pertes les français sont appelés à
être confiné le 11 mai ils pourront être
des confiner le confinement et le plus
strict moyen le plus le seul moyen
d'agir efficacement contre l'épidémie ce
sont les mots de manuel mac pour ce soir
est donc pour le lundi 11 mai le
président de la république a notamment
annoncé la réouverture des
établissements scolaires à partir du 11
mai nous rouvrirons progressivement les
crèches les écoles les collèges et les
lycées
c'est pour moi une priorité car la
situation actuelle creuse des inégalités
trop d'enfants notamment dans les
quartiers populaires dans nos campagnes
sont privés d'école sans avoir accès au
numérique et ne peuvent être aidés de la
même manière par les parents dans cette
période les inégalités de logements les
inégalités entre familles sont encore
plus marqués c'est pourquoi
nos enfants doivent pouvoir retrouver le
chemin des classes
le gouvernement dans la concertation
aura à aménager des règles particulières
organisée différemment le temps et
l'espace
bien protégé nos enseignants et nos
enfants avec le matériel nécessaire pour
les étudiants de l'enseignement
supérieur les cours ne reprendront pas
physiquement jusqu'à l'été le
gouvernement précisera pour chacun la
bonne organisation qui sera nécessaire
en particulier pour les examens et les
concours on se maquille signera
également le retour au travail d'un
certain nombre de français en revanche
pas de réouverture pour les lieux
accueillant du public tels que les
restaurants les cafés ou encore les
cinémas et puis le président de la
république a expliqué que les personnes
les plus vulnérables les personnes âgées
des personnes malades pourraient être
appelées à se confiner encore un peu
plus longtemps que donc cette date du 11
mai le président de la république qui a
concédé quelques ratés quelques failles
quelques insuffisances ce sont ces mots
nous n'étions pas assez préparés n'y a
pas assez de matériel c'est vrai que
c'était une question qui était abordée
très régulièrement ces derniers mois ces
dernières semaines pardon par les
français at on suffisamment de masques
de tests ces deux questions ont été
abordées par le président de la
république il a promis à l'issue de ces
mesures de confinement toutes les
personnes présentant des symptômes
seront exclues en écosse nous aurons à
partir du 11 mai une organisation
nouvelle pour réussir cet état
l'utilisation la plus large possible des
tests et la détection est une arme
privilégiée pour sortir au bon moment du
confinement
d'ici là et dans les prochaines semaines
nous allons continuer d'augmenter le
nombre de tests faits chaque jour ses
skis depuis quinze jours et fait durant
les semaines à venir j'ai demandé que
ces tests soient d'abord pratiqué sur
nos aînés nos soignants et les plus
fragiles et que nous
ici on continuer de mobiliser partout
tous les moyens de faire des tests c'est
à dire tous les laboratoires publics et
tous les laboratoires privés
le 11 mai nous serons en capacité de
tester toute personne présentant des
symptômes
les personnes ayant le virus pourront
ainsi être mises en quarantaine prises
en charge et suivi par un médecin
parmi les autres annonces notable de la
part du chef de l'état on pourra noter
l'accroissement des aides aux
entreprises encore l'aide aux familles
les plus modestes avec des enfants ainsi
que les étudiants précaires une macro
qui a fait part d'une certaine forme
d'humilité je n'ai pas les réponses à
toutes les questions que vous me posez
c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles le contour de ce
déconfinement pourra continuer à se
redessiner ses prochaines semaines avec
d'autres consultations à venir de la
part du président dira merci thomas
bonnin en direct de l'elysée on parlait
et quelques instants des tests qui sont
évidemment une condition nécessaire un
déconfinement réussi autre condition
nécessaire on en a beaucoup parlé il
s'agit des masques vous le savez on est
en pénurie de masques sur le territoire
français et bien emmanuel macron a
promis que des masques grand public
serait prêt au moment où le confinement
strict s'arrêterait c'est à dire le 11
mai je vous propose d'écouter emmanuel
macron sur ce point alors étions nous
préparer à cette crise à l'évidence pas
assez mais nous avons fait face en
france comme partout ailleurs
nous avons donc dû parer à l'urgence
prendre des décisions difficiles à
partir d'informations partielles souvent
changeante nous adapter sans cesse car
ce virus était inconnue et il porte
encore aujourd'hui beaucoup de mystère
le moment soyons honnêtes a révélé des
failles les insuffisances
comme tous les pays du monde nous avons
manqué de blues de gants de gel
hydroalcoolique
nous n'avons pas pu distribuer autant de
masques que nous l'aurions voulu pour
nos soignants pour les personnels
s'occupant de nos aînés pour les
infirmières les aides à domicile dès
l'instant où ces problèmes ont été
identifiés
nous nous sommes mobilisés gouvernement
collectivités locales industriels
associations pour produire et pour
acquérir le matériel nécessaire mais je
mesure pleinement que lorsque l'on est
au front il est difficile d'entendre
qu'une pénurie mondiale empêche les
livraisons les commandes sont désormais
passées surtout nos entreprises
françaises et nos travailleurs ont
répondu présent et une production comme
en temps de guerre s'est mise en place
nous avons réouvert des lignes pour
produire nous avons réquisitionné d'ici
trois semaines nous aurons imaginer le
multiplier par cinq la production de
masques pour nos soignants en france et
nous aurons produit des 1000 respirateur
supplémentaires de plus sur notre sol
c'est respirateur si précieux en
réanimation
grâce à ces efforts nous saurons faire
face et nous allons continuer à
distribuer davantage d'équipements pour
réagir à cette allocution d' emmanuel
macron nous sommes maintenant en direct
avec arthur de grave communicants et
auteur bonsoir arthur de grave merci
d'être avec nous un sondage paru ce
week-end dans le journal du dimanche
sondage ifop seuls 38% des français font
confiance au gouvernement pour gérer
cette crise
est ce que cette allocution d' emmanuel
macron ce soir est de nature selon vous
à restaurer la confiance des français
alors c'est difficile de répondre à
cette question puisque on a une opinion
de public aujourd'hui qu'il n'en est pas
vraiment une puisque tout le monde est
confiné
donc on ne sait pas vraiment ce qui se
passe dans la tête des gens et les gens
se parlent moins ou pas par des camions
habituel donc savoir comment va réagir
l'opinion c'est difficile à dire donc on
verra demain je veux pas jouer les
marabouts
par contre ce qui est vrai c'est que ce
qui a sans doute participé largement à
cette perte de confiance dans le
gouvernement dans la gestion de la crise
a été une certaine cacophonie une
communication assez erratiques ou le
président de la république donc le 16
mars et le 16 mars pardon fait un
discours assez grandiloquent avec une
structure en dana fort sur la guerre je
vais vous parler sur toute la structure
de de la forme du discours de ce soir
plutôt que sur le fond je pense que
beaucoup de monde le fera mieux que moi
ce soir et pour autant qu'on avait par
exemple le 16 mars le président de la
république qui nous disait que nous
étions en guerre que quoi qu'il en coûte
les mesures soient prises qu'il fallait
qu'on fasse autre chose de notre vivant
près qu'on profite de tout cela pour
lire pour se recentrer sur l'important
est le lendemain les ministes de travail
qui dit non par contre vous avez m'a
coupé va falloir retourner au boulot là
effectivement on a des mots qui engage
dans un discours qui se veut plus sobre
une forme de discours d'atterrissage
c'est à dire qu'on a moins d'effets de
manche on a un ton moins grandiloquent
moins lyrique quelque chose de plus
factuel et un horizon temporel assez
assez restreint le dire par là que on
est encore dans ce discours on donne un
horizon de sortie de crise sanitaire en
tout cas de sortie de confinement pas de
sortie de crise sanitaire
vous prenez une forme d'incertitude sur
ce plan là et sur la presse sur ce qui
viendra après on reste assez vague pour
autant j'ai quand même noter quelques
mots qui font presque mine de conversion
dans la bouche des manuels mais quand
j'ai entendu le mode relocalisation j'ai
entendu une bonne planification et ça
c'est intéressant alors la question pour
moi à ce stade c'est de voir comment
concilier ce propos présidentiels ce
soir on qui se veut qu ici faveur je
veux dire par là qu'on fait on a eu des
éditorialistes constamment eric le
boucher dans les échos hier me
semble-t-il qu'ils lèvent
il faut sortir du confinement maintenant
pour sauver l'économie
un certain nombre d'économistes plutôt
proche du pouvoir porter des positions
assez similaire
là apparemment ce n'est pas notre
chantier non déconfinement c'est pas
tout de suite ça va prendre du temps on
va apprendre à vivre avec
donc on a à priori un contre-pied qui a
pris de ce point de vue là la question
c'est comment réaccorder son discours
avec les déclarations qui lui étaient
prêtées fait notamment je pense
du côté de bruno le maire hier et
aujourd'hui dans la foulée notamment des
déclarations du président du medef qui
appelait en soit qui évoque l après en
disant il va falloir faire des efforts
il va falloir revenir sur les congés
payés il va falloir revenir sur sur le
temps de travail dont qui annonçait
quand même un après qui n'était pas
forcément mon nouveau concret comme
certains peuvent l'appeler de leurs
oeufs
le fameux monde après qu'on trouve dans
certaines tribunes assez inspiré qui se
veulent très d'autres services comme la
droite à gauche sur l'internet
donc ça ne semblait pas annoncer ce
genre de choses
comment réconcilier des déclarations de
ce type là avec le discours présidentiel
de ce soir donc ce sont des mots forts
ce sont des mots qui engage une forme
d'atterrissage quand même on a quand
même une communication élyséenne qui
était un peu pataud série arthur de
grave
effectivement il a commencé son discours
emmanuel macron la france à l'évidence
n'était pas assez préparés à la crise
c'était important peut-être d'utiliser
une parole de vérité effectivement la
france n'était pas prête à cette crise
difficile oui effectivement à ce stade
étant donné va la perte de confiance que
vous évoquez tout à l'heure de continuer
à expliquer que tout allait bien que non
non il n'y avait pas eu je veux dire ça
fait partie aussi des éléments des ratés
de la communication gouvernementale de
ces dernières semaines d'avoir eu
différentes voix au sein du gouvernement
qu'ils sont allés contre l'évidence je
vais pas refaire la liste on ennuie un
certain nombre au cours des semaines
écoulées
là effectivement ça participe très
largement de cette perte de confiance et
de cette défiance même du gouvernement
donc effectivement c'est un en termes de
captatio benevolentiae pour pour prendre
un vieux terme de rhétorique
on ne peut pas faire autrement dans ce
cas là effectivement que reconnaître
reconnaître une part d'erreur
ce que je constate aussi donc c'est il
ya quelque chose qui m'a frappé c'est
que la métaphore de la guerre
la métaphore du nous sommes en guerre et
passe en demi teinte on entend quand
même première ligne 2e ligne à des cas
quelques termes jour les ti-cats le
guerrier mais globalement on s'en
éloigne un petit peu on célèbre même eu
l'esprit français
un rigolo qu'il appelait pourtant
lui-même les gaulois réfractaires s'est
méchamment il ya encore quelques mois en
disant que justement les français
continuent à avoir des débats continuer
à faire de la politique continue à
critiquer et en s'en félicitant la ce
qui est une rupture par rapport à cette
ligne aussi cette première ligne qui
venait du 16 mars qui était cette ligne
de la guerre et donc l'union sacrée donc
quiconque quiconque critique rayon
d'action du gouvernement aujourd'hui ne
serait pas ne s'engagerait pas dans la
lutte contre le wild eyes là on a
effectivement une petite inflexion de ce
côté là mais encore une fois je suis
très curieux de voir la suite concrète
qui sera donnée à ces déclarations et
comment le reste de la communication
gouvernementale va s'accorder autour de
cette de l'intervention de ce soir il
faut ce sont des mots qui engage et on
demande à voir
merci beaucoup arthur de grave
communicants et aux terres d'avoir été
avec nous et emmanuel macron a donc
annoncé la réouverture progressive des
écoles collèges et lycées dès le 11 mai
prochain un soulagement pour la plupart
des parents d'élèves de la maternelle au
lycée ce sont quelques 12 millions
d'élèves qui étaient jusqu'ici confinée
chez eux continuent en tant bien que mal
les cours à la maison les étudiants eux
reprendront les courts physiquement
après l'été on écoute le président de la
république sur ce point à partir du 11
mai nous rouvrirons progressivement les
crèches les écoles les collèges et les
lycées
c'est pour moi une priorité car la
situation actuelle creuse des inégalités
trop d'enfants notamment dans les
quartiers populaires dans nos campagnes
sont privés d'école sans avoir accès au
numérique et ne peuvent être aidés de la
même manière par les parents dans cette
période les inégalités de logements les
inégalités entre familles sont encore
plus marqués c'est pourquoi nos enfants
doivent pouvoir retrouver le chemin des
classes
le gouvernement dans la concertation
aura à aménager des règles particulières
organisée
différemment le temps et l'espace bien
protégé nos enseignants et nos enfants
avec le matériel nécessaire pour les
étudiants de l'enseignement supérieur
les cours ne reprendront pas
physiquement jusqu'à l'été le
gouvernement précisera pour chacun la
bonne organisation qui sera nécessaire
en particulier pour les examens et les
concours
pour réussir nous sommes avec français
popineau secrétaire général et porte
parole du snuipp fsu le premier syndicat
des enseignants du primaire bonsoir
madame merci d'être avec nous reprise de
l'école le 11 mai on avait lu dans la
presse dans certaines presses voilà
l'éventualité de pousser jusqu'en
septembre vous quelle est votre réaction
ce soir de se dire il faut encore tenir
un mois ont plutôt le soulagement que ça
reprenne néanmoins quand même le 11 mai
ni la ville où j'allais dire parce que
bien sûr nous avons le souhait de
reprendre l'école avant l'été parce que
c'est important pour les enfants et les
enfants qui ne vivent pas le confinement
tous de la même manière et c'est
important de quilles et une reprise de
l'école
en revanche leurs 11 mai dans le
discours du président il ya des
contradictions parce que si le 11 mai on
ne peut pas ouvrir les cinémas on ne
peut pas ouvrir les restaurants comment
pourrions nous ouvrir une école où on
sait que c'est un lieu de transmission
quand même très actif donc effectivement
ça ça nous interroge
on se demande s'il n'ya pas un petit peu
d'imprudence là dedans bien sûr il faut
que les gens reprennent le travail nous
en sommes absolument conscient
nous avons nous aussi envie de retrouver
nos élèves c'est pas le sujet mais il
faut le faire en étant sûr sur le plan
sanitaire
il s'agit pas de reprendre l'école et
ensuite de se retrouver confiné quinze
jours plus tard donc là on a une vraie
inquiétude
et puis effectivement il faut travailler
à cette progressivité
ça veut dire que on ne pourra pas
revenir sereinement en classe tous
ensemble il faudra envisager les demies
groupe voire des tiers de groupe il
faudra des récréations échelonnée et
puis il faut effectivement que tout le
personnel adultes autour enseignants
mais aussi personnel de cantine zem et
caetera et les protections nécessaires
or nous savons que nous courons après
les protections à c'est vraiment devenu
très compliqué donc il va falloir que
nous ayons beaucoup de détails sur cette
histoire dure 11 mai et que nous soyons
sûrs que d'un point de vue sanitaire
personne ne prend de risques parce que
si les enfants reviennent à l'école vous
savez c'est très difficile les gestes
barrière chez des enfants jeunes donc
bah ils se touchent ils jouent ensemble
bien sûr et puis ensuite il rentre à la
maison et puis éventuellement ils vont
s'élever papier ou mamie donc vous
imaginez là la chaîne de transmission
qui peut encore avoir lieu si le trait
le 11 mai nous ne pouvons pas ouvrir les
restaurants nous ne comprenons pas que
nous pouvons ouvrir les écoles tout en
disant qu'il sera important à un moment
donné de reprendre la casse bien
évidemment et c'est vrai pour les
inégalités et faisons le en étant sûr de
ne mettre aucun personnel en danger et
que la santé de tous sera toujours
protégé
c'est ça ma priorité avant la pédagogie
avant l'économie
il faut maintenir la santé de chacun on
entend effectivement votre inquiétude en
tant que représentant des enseignants
pensez vous qu emmanuel macron
en tout cas son ministre jean michel
blanquer a peut-être consulté les
syndicats les enseignants avant de
prendre cette décision parce qu'il est
riche que peut-être je vous pose
d'ailleurs la question ce soir de se
heurter à un refus tout simplement de la
part des enseignants à à retourner
travailler le 11 mai ce que vous iriez
jusque là justement un temps de droit de
retrait tout simplement de peur que le
virent que le virus circule c'est le
sanitaire qui nous guide c'est pas c'est
pas l'avis des uns ou des autres c'est
le sanitaire qui nous guide candy ems
candy l'inserm
voilà c'est ça qui est important si on
nous dit qu'il n'y a aucun risque pour
la santé
je crois que tous les enseignants seront
ravis de reprendre le chemin de l'école
et les enfants aussi
et c'est important pour tout le monde
mais ce dont on veut avoir l'assurance
c'est effectivement est ce qu'il n'ya
pas de mise en danger de la santé
hélas dans ce discours contradictoires
on a des doutes alors sur le plan du
travail oui nous travaillons avec le
ministère sur une reprise éventuelle
c'est un scénario que nous avions
envisagé que nous continuons à
travailler sur une reprise effectivement
avant l'été le scénario demi mais
n'avait pas été produit jusqu alors nous
étions plutôt sur un scénario en juin
avec comme je me disais des étapes qui
des deux groupes ou des pierres de
groupe avec une protection évidemment
des adultes et des enfants
ça veut dire la france est papineau
pardon vous comme mc dont vous êtes
étonné ce soir vous en tant
qu'enseignant vous disiez on était
plutôt sur un scénario de de joie vous
vous attendiez pas cette décision d'
emmanuel macron deux reprises d'école le
11 mai non mais je le redis nous notre
préoccupation c'est pas de l'eau mais ça
nous pose pas de problème en soi ce qui
est étonnant dans le discours c'est que
le 11 mai on note bien que la reprise
des collectifs les événements de l'été
sont annulés donc tous les collectifs
sont annulés sauf l'école c'est ça qui
nous interroge aujourd'hui et on se
demande si derrière ça il n'y a pas de
l'imprudence alors pardonnez moi ça me
coupe et on a bien compris justement
mais emmanuel macron m'étais
en avant effectivement pas des raisons
sanitaires il a bien dit qu'il y aurait
besoin d'aménagements de règles
particulières pour protéger notamment
les professeurs mais il a mis en avant
les inégalités peut-être voilà des
élèves plus défavorisés que d'autres
pour qui c'était extrêmement compliqué
de ne pas les allées à l'école quelle
est votre réaction par rapport à cet
argument bien sûr nous avons eu aussi
évoqué les inégalités depuis longtemps à
nous savons qu on a une école qui est
inégalitaire les inégalités les existe
la crise les a seulement mis en lumière
à mais les inégalités mais
malheureusement elles existent ce sont
des inégalités souvent au social
culturel et cetera donc elles sont à
prendre en compte par l'école c'est bien
ce que nous réclamons depuis depuis
longtemps et lorsque c'est effectivement
il y aura une reprise pour qu'elle soit
sereine
il faudra aussi que nous soyons entouré
de psychologues sans doute de médecins
d'infirmières parce qu'il y aura des
enfants qui auront vécu le confinement
d'une manière extrêmement difficile et
avant de reprendre l'école avant de
reprendre les apprentissages ils devront
se réparer donc il va falloir que nous
ayons des personnels avec nous pour nous
et des assistantes sociales infirmières
psychologues enseignants spécialisés il
faudra que l'école soit entouré pour
pouvoir aider tous ces enfants c'est
très important ce n'est pas parce que
l'école va reprendre les problèmes
seront réglés il y aura des traumatismes
y compris liés à la perte des éléments
de la famille une dernière petite
question rapidement tant qu'enseignante
vous inquiète par rapport au programme à
ce que vous aurez le temps
de rattraper ce programme après des
semaines de perdues
l'erreur serait effectivement de faire
la course programme sur le dernier mois
qui nous resterait d'apprentissage ce
serait une erreur ce temps là va être un
temps où on va se retrouver où on va
comme je le disais panser des blessures
on va se remettre à niveau
il faut envisager que cette année
effectivement ça s'est arrêté le 13 mars
au soir et on reprendra la classe au
moment où elle s'est arrêtée sur le
programme des années suivantes
aucun enfant ne sera pénalisé mais il
faudra effectivement revoir comment on
réajuste les programmes dans les années
qui viennent pour effectivement
rattraper ce moment où l'école aura été
mis en sommeil
c'est évident pour le fera
progressivement mais on peut garantir
que la scolarité de l'enfant ne s'en
ressentira pas il y aura des mois de
retard mais ça se comblera et on ne le
verra plus d'ici quelques temps il faut
rassurer tout le monde à ce niveau là
mais mais le travail sera fait les
enseignants sauront comment réajuster
les programmes pour que tout se fasse
tranquillement et pour que tous les
enfants et tout ce qu'il faut pour
réussir
merci beaucoup france est un popineau
secrétaire général porte parole du slip
est fait suite à l'arrêté avec nous et
dans le contexte de la pandémie due
coronavirus des français ont subi des
agressions verbales ces dernières
semaines des actes qui ont eu lieu dans
les zones frontalières allemande
plusieurs maires de villes de sa région
limitrophe du nord-est du pays ont
dénoncé ce comportement anti français
puis la ministre de l'économie de la
sarre a présenté ses excuses de la part
de l'allemagne enfin ce week-end le
ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères a condamné ces agressions
verbales écouter le corps de la virus ne
connaît pas de nationalité
c'est la même chose pour la dignité
humaine cela fait mal de voir comment
nos amis français sont parfois insultes
et a attaqué à cause du coc vite 19
un tel comportement n'est pas possible
nous sommes dans le même bateau
on entend dire que les français sont
insultés et qu'on leur jettent des oeufs
quiconque fait cela pêche contre
l'amitié de nos peuples
je présente mes excuses à nos amis
français pour ces incidents isolés
et pour parler de l'allemagne 1 qui
résiste d'ailleurs bien mieux que ses
voisins européens face aux vives virus
nous sommes en direct depuis hambourg
avec martin dans l'isère sociologue et
membre du parti
d-link et c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir martin
dalair merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france ce petit réaction tout
d'abord à ce qu'on vient d'entendre des
français apparemment insulté le ministre
des finances qui présente ses excuses
une réaction de votre côté effectivement
et c'est une chose qui s'est excusé car
il ne faut pas en force et les
nationalismes qui que nous soyons
sempéré de crise ou non cela ne peut pas
être exposés les identités nationales
force certaine personne à blâmer
d'autres pour cette maladie
alors c'est vrai que l'allemagne fait
figure d'exemple un lan man qui
respectent les consignes de confinement
qui semble parfois il est vrai faire
mieux que nous notamment sur le bilan la
manière de traiter l'épidémie alors je
me pose la question ce soir selon vous
qu'est ce que vous faites mieux vous les
allemands que nous à les français dans
la gestion de cette épidémie
je ne pense pas que nous fassions pas
que ce soit de mieux voter la gestion de
l'épidémie
crise est très plurielle il ya beaucoup
de sujets différents qu'il faut traiter
afin d'analyser les raisons pour
laquelle dans un pays pour y boire plus
de contamination d'autres par exemple
une promiscuité plus grande entre
personnes âgées et personnes jeunes ou
nombre de personnes qui sont vulnérables
face au virus ont en allemagne nous
avons des manières d méthode de décompte
différentes par exemple nous ne comptons
dans certaines régions les morts que si
le cours d'un virus est la cause de mort
avéré alors que dans d'autres
l'ue compte on ne compte pas s'y est la
personne serait morte de toute façon
donc il est difficile de dire en ce
moment si un pays se sentir mieux qu'un
autre
bon c'est vrai que je vous coupe mc do
les airs mais on nous présente
l'allemagne comme 1 5 fois moins de
morts qu'en france vous vous remettez
peut-être en compte le comptage tout
simplement de des morts liés aux
coronavirus s'expliquerait cette
disparité entre les deux bilans selon
vous ce n'est pas la seule raison
il y a beaucoup de causes différentes si
prévoir beaucoup de raisons mais cela
pourrait en être une
il pourrait également y avoir des
raisons liées à la façon dont les
personnes mènent leur vie quotidienne
dont les hôpitaux sont construits par
exemple en italie beaucoup de personnes
contaminées par le coronavirus visé
vivaient dans des conditions très
polluée donc ils ont été frappés plus
durement par le virus que d'autres
personnes dans d'autres environnements
si les hôpitaux ils sont bien situées
si il
non pas trop souffert de politique qui
alors c'est mieux que d autres régions
les hôpitaux sont bien financés
il ya donc beaucoup de raisons à une
s'agit là que de spéculations n'ont pas
vraiment dire qu'un pays s'en tire bien
mieux qu'un autre ou pourquoi surtout il
y a tant de raisons qui pourraient
expliquer que nous ne connaissons pas
tous cas il faudrait maintenant plutôt
étudier la crise et non pas au niveau
national ce n'est pas l'important
l'important c'est que dans une telle
crise il faudrait comprendre que le
capitalisme néolibéral nous amener dans
cette crise c'est une crise capitaliste
qu'on street s'est effondré en janvier
et nous sommes maintenant dans une crise
économique car le coronavirus cause
encore d'autres problèmes il faut
observer qui se sert de cette pandémie
et de quelle façon il faudra se servir
avant que vous expliquer je me demandais
en quoi c'est une crise lié au
capitalisme selon vous parce que des
épidémies
malheureusement l'histoire on a eu plein
on n'était pas encore dans un processus
capitaliste en quoi c'est une crise
capitaliste selon vous pardonnez moi de
vous avoir coupé mais c'est important de
vous poser la question quand même le
virus lui-même n'ont pas causé par le
capitalisme mais les circonstances de la
gestion de crise pourrait être
différente par exemple si et tous les
hôpitaux
si tous ces hôpitaux n'est pas été
privatisée alors s'il n'y avait pas
autant d'exportation
de d'équipements médicaux seraient
nécessaires il n'y aurait pas
d'exclusion de certaines personnes des
systèmes de soins comme cela existe aux
états unis si l'état prenait en charge
le système de santé bien plus que dans
les pays néo libéraux les résultats ne
seraient donc pas aussi grave
je pense que si l'on observe le virus on
peut voir la façon dont les gens se
servent du virus par exemple l'un de mes
amis a dû se rendre au travail tous les
matins en bus
une demi heure à l'aller ils de
meilleurs retours et dans le bus bien
sûr les gens soutiennent très proches
les uns des autres et il n'est pas
nécessaire était pas nécessaire pour lui
de se rendre au travail
même ses chefs lui disait de rester chez
lui
mais la compagnie les supérieurs disait
qu'il fallait continuer à travailler et
cela est vraiment incohérent si on veut
gérer une crise convenablement
il faut comprendre pourquoi est il
possible dans certaines régions de la
société de rester au travail et tant
d'autres non si les gens restent
éloignés de 1 mètre 50
alors il est possible de le contaminer
personne mais si l'on prend le bus là où
on est écartée que de 30 à 40 cm alors
il peut y avoir une propagation en plus
importante
il faudrait observer ce qui se passe et
comprendre pourquoi ce virus se
développe ainsi il faut aider les
personnes exclues
il faut découvrir ce qui est nécessaire
afin d'empêcher la propagation du virus
mais il faut également être très clair
sur les personnes qui meurent par
exemple en allemagne en 2013
il ya une épidémie de grippe et 40000
personnes sont mortes en six mois le
cours n'a virus et une pandémie et
beaucoup de personnes sont mortes
également et chaque mort est de trop
donc effectivement il faut prévenir il
faut également comprendre pourquoi
certaines personnes sont touchées et pas
d'autres pourquoi nous la gérons de
cette façon pourquoi de telles mesures
incohérentes sont mises en place
merci et ensuite avec un budget général
on pourra prévenir la propagation du
virus
ou alors on pourra en tout cas essayer
d'encourager certaines personnes plus
vulnérables
donc nous devons être très prudents afin
que ce virus ne permettent pas d'élargir
encore le fossé entre pauvres et riches
merci beaucoup martin a dans le vert
sociologue et membre du parti die linke
et voilà ce que nous pouvions dire sur
cette spéciale 1 crise du corona virus
avec l'allocution d'emmanuel macron vous
en rappelle les principales annonces un
déconfinement partiel à partir du 11 mai
la réouverture des crèches des écoles et
des collèges ainsi que des lycées
sachant que l'enseignement supérieur et
bien ce sera physiquement remis après
l'été plusieurs mesures évidemment sur
le chômage partiel qui va continuer se
multiplier
même la fermeture des frontières de
schengen jusqu'à nouvel ordre les hôtels
les bars les restaurants eux aussi
resteront fermés jusqu'à nouvel ordre
avec des festivals annulés jusqu'à
minimum la mi juillet voilà en substance
qu'on pouvait retenir de ce discours de
près d'une demi-heure les détails ce
sera demain matin avec la première
édition 8 heures du matin heure
française
on reviendra sur ses annonces des
manuels dacron avec évidemment les
réactions excellente fin de soirée à
tous sur rt france
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90